ein bisschen okay du hast dir bist dann
auf ich gewinner ist ein 10 1
nein was du kannst ja korrekt der bruder
so sollten so sollten brüder seien
herzlich kommt zu diesem junge leute ich
bin wieder da für euch mit einem neuen
video ich bin zurück von splash und
hoffen damit bekommen die mission
verfolgen das splash war
da habe ich mir einige tage dann volle
volle möhre die kanne gegeben will jetzt
aber wieder zurück unter den lebenden
und bin zurück und ein video für euch
sollte das wird selbst die besonders die
ruhigsten die friedlichsten unter euch
aus der fassung bringt er hat gesehen
dass ich ein neues hilfe video und in
diesen hilfen video taucht ein junger
mann auf der einfach deshalb achtet mal
während dieses videos auf eure gefühle
leute und schreiben an die kommentare ob
es geschafft habt nicht sauer zu werden
ich werde mich ist werden genau null
personen schaffen denn das video heißt
psyche bruder mein bruder macht mich
verrückt und wir sind schon direkt an
der fahrt zu dem typ schneidet hier geht
es nicht mit rechten dingen zu
also wir sehen heute eine liebenswerte
deutsche familie wären auf der linken
seite den bruder auf der rechten seite
die schwester also leute eine ganz
normale liebenswerte deutsche familie
man kümmert sich umeinander man hat
einander liebt aber jetzt kommt der eine
von denen der bruder ist einfach nur
allein schon dieser tonfall da will man
schon direkt wenn man direkt rein passen
in dieses gesicht ja schön schön das
waren wir versprochen hat dass es heute
lasagne gibt okay aber wir kommen in der
realität okay wir kommen im echten leben
es gibt halt fucking nudeln gibt keine
lasagne jetzt für dich sehr froh dass
überhaupt das kriegsbeil hat versprochen
das hatte das animiert das reicht
eigentlich schon leute also bei mir ist
also diese nicht aufregend schön ich
jetzt schon vorbei wenn ich das wie
gesagt heute diese nicht aufregend schön
ist es bei mir hier schon vorbei wenn
ich jemanden schon mit so einem tonfall
reden höre man hat versprochen
das wusste ich nicht aber ich kann dir
morgen als anja machen wir morgen morgen
das wort weißt was morgen bedeutet du
musst nicht packen jedes wort
wiederholen was seine schwester sagt
okay und vor allem nicht in diesen
widerlichen tonfall
nein ich wusste aber dass ist genau das
gleiche das sind auch nudeln mit
tomatensoße sicher diese geste dem
unteren rand dieses was für einen pass
hatte wie kann man so sagen was ich will
kurz mal seinen namen wissen um den
anzusprechen ok-team timmy und sandy
sind dass also der jünger ist ja okay
okay
deine schwester koch scharf für dich
okay diese kümmert sich und legt so
weißt du bist ihr bruder so natürlich
macht sie was für dich soll sie macht
die nudel was sein dank dafür
diese geste das schon wieder das falsche
gekocht aber lasagne
ich will sie nicht morgen ich will sie
jetzt ja und was dann okay erzählt hat
der mutter so hey mama mama die sandy
hat für mich gekocht und es war keine
lasagne
obwohl ist eigentlich nichts dass es
lasagne geben soll jede mutter in
deutschland so und jetzt sehr froh dass
so etwas zu essen bekommen hast deine
fresse ich werde davon erzählen sie wird
wieder total fertig sein
willst du das mal wieder zusammenbricht
ich will bittere diesem video so ein
kommentar haben so dass es der ein
schlag ins gesicht button okay wenn
dieser kommentar unter diesem video
nicht 5000 likes erreicht dann fühle ich
meinen glauben an die menschheit sitzt
du das mal wieder zusammenbricht
ok 13.000 likes auf den tisch schlagen
button 10.000 likes minimum was für ein
ekelhaftes wesentlicher du siehst aus
wie fucking asiatischer gollum weiter
stell dich nicht so an
rothschild okay du hast immer noch deine
fangen pasta-party okay ich habe auch
keiner hunger ich würde mich freuen über
die nudeln und du kleines prinzessin
heute ist keine lassen jedes thema
willkommen wir nehmen man kann sich
immer das haben was man will auch immer
da sie hatte gollum ist und eine rote
kappe verkehrt herum trägt
ok also schauen wir geht es in diesem
haus hat nicht nur diesen wunderbaren
bezaubernden jungen mann sondern auch
ein vater der irgendwie eine affäre
hatte und dann irgendwie abgehauen ist
passiert dass irgendwie ausgeplaudert
und deswegen macht er jetzt
schuldgefühle ja korrekte bruder so
sollten sollten brüder seien ja also
deine schwester ist wirklich unter aller
sau
das verhalten was ihr den tag legt geht
gar nicht ich meine die kocht für dich
kleine rohde ist ansonsten doch einfach
im wirklich ekelhafter mensch komplettes
vom verhalten her viel zu aggressiv viel
zu unfreundlich
gott sei dank gibt es chemie der immer
wieder mit absoluter vorbildfunktion
vorangeht freundlich zuvorkommend
asiatischer gollum perfekt
was also leute wir sehen es geht sanft
weiter in diesem wunderbaren der
haushalt der liebenswerte bruder hat
seine schwester ganz dezent und
freundlich darauf aufmerksam gemacht
dass er sich jetzt einen döner gehen
holt weil ihm das gekochte essen nicht
schmeckt jetzt hat er sich folglich
weise noch ein küchenmesser in die hand
genommen um seiner schwester zu zeigen
wie man so ein messer richtig hält das
wusste sie nämlich noch nicht deswegen
ist auch sohn ali im gesicht passt ganz
gut auf madame okay hast du was ich mit
dem teil hier alles anstellen kann
ja das eigentlich mal eine richtige
richtung so du hältst dich genau richtig
rum so ist gut einfach so wie das jetzt
gerade hält sondern und dann probieren
was wirklich mega geiler trick ist wenn
du das messer suchen hält also die
klingel zeit konntest du dir probiere
einfach mal du wirst dich glauben was da
passiert ein voller kraft da hinten
drauf zu schlagen macht einfach okay
fragt nicht weiter nach erinnerst du
dich an deinen goldhamster flecki
erinnerst du dich pass auf sonst
rutschig mit dem ding aus dann triffst
du nächste mal nicht nur deinen hamster
leute unser liebenswerter freund
asiatischer gollum ist weiterhin
unaufhaltsam beziehungsweise was sage
ich unaufhaltsam ist weiterhin ein
vorbildlicher bruder geht an der stellt
sommer darauf ein dass er in der
vergangenheit auch so nett war den
goldhamster seiner schwester der
natürlich seine schwester schrecklich
genervt hat einfach umzubringen
so nach dem motto dann hat man schwester
endlich ruhe sehr vorbildlich ist
verhalten an der stelle also ganz so
ernst frage ist die einzige frage die
man sich hier stellt bei dieser handlung
ist warum ist dieser typ noch nicht in
der klapse chemie geht her absolut zu
weit das ist kein kleiner streit unter
geschwistern mit ein bisschen schubsen
und kratzen und beißen aber ach so ach
so gut dass wir den expert an dieser
stelle haben weil ich dachte das wäre so
eine kleine kapelle unter geschwistern
die manchmal hat wenn man so ich immer
das gleiche spielzeug streitet oder so
ich war wirklich kurz davor das zu
denken dankeschön dass wir nochmal der
zwischenruf kam jetzt mal ganz im ernst
sicher das war die beste psycho
manipulation danach hat er ein fucking
messer gezogen und das seine schwester
vors gesicht gehalten hätte jetzt also
wusstet ihr schon dass das kein normaler
streit ist eine richtig geile aktion
haben muss dass muss irgendwann muss
sich darum kümmern
der läuft ja sagte geht losen döner zu
holen kommt mit dem teller pommes an
aber wer seine schwester macht nudel
wenn er eigentlich das an die welt das
geht natürlich überhaupt nicht stört sie
ist so gestärkt die eicher und wenn ich
es nicht mache dann macht ihr jetzt nur
noch was ich will und was geht mal
überhaupt so weiß wirklich nur in weimar
nein wieder sehr viele dinge falsch
diese szene einerseits zu der typ der
rechts kommst du mit seinem ersten satz
überhaupt rein und verpackt den ersten
satz direkt umgeht
auf jeden fall heute ja weil ich
definitiv wie man mit weimar umgeht an
der stelle könnte das glaube ich sicher
auch bestätigen ich habe ja wieso 80%
mädels als zuschauern ich denke mal der
großteil von euch ist es auch immer gut
drauf und hält es für angemessen wenn
man mit messer bedroht wird werden man
redet also geht man ja allgemein mit
mitfahrer klappt du bist also der
psychopath im haus ich meine was
eigentlich der leute sorry es tut mir
leid wirst du ein bisschen ausgerutscht
der wahl das wollte ich natürlich sagen
was ich sagen wollte ist bekennt sich
alle von unseren eltern zu hause und die
haben wenn ihr mal durchgreifen mussten
okay ja sieht ja die männer heraus haben
die natürlich auch lebensbedrohlich
waffen gezogen und die gegen menschen
gerichtet die deutlich schwächer sind
als die körperlichen kein kind hat auch
zu kleckern wenn sich vom eigenen vater
mit messer bedroht wird das wissen wir
alle
richtig lecker das machst du besser wie
ich ach quatsch
keller können so gut kochen wie du ach
komm stellt sein licht nicht unter den
scheffel das heißt so richtig gemacht ja
und in dieser wunderbaren familie gibt
natürlich eine mutter dass die schauen
wir hier
ich fahre jetzt ganz ehrlich aber nur
auf den moment wo der bruder wieder
reinkommt und den laden mal komplett
auseinander nimmt hier auch teenies im
park ein paar kinder abstechen ja ja und
die heutigen ja auch rentner anzünden
oder so was meinte er ja so wie immer
eigentlich
[Musik]
nächster akt bei unserer freundlichen
typisch deutschen familie die mutter hat
scheinbar gerade eine existenzkrise
schaut sich bilder von ihrem ex mann an
der sich irgendwann mal betrogen hat
oder so und hat aber da war einfach so 0
rote augen man ist einfach so dass
jemand die einfach so wasser ins gesicht
geschüttet hat produktionsqualität ist
da ich springe aber kurz davor nicht wir
gerne mal sehen ich habe mir die szene
ja ausgesucht ich glaube ich ein guter
schluss kommt dass leute schaut mal kurz
rein
das wird nie wieder vorkommen nie wieder
perfekt ja vielen dank für diesen
schlusspunkte mir wirklich einfach
vorbild nicht wirklich in dieser folge
verhalten hast und ich wollte dir an der
stelle ganz ehrlich noch mal sagen bring
dich einfach um wobei ich das wohl auch
sagen musste hätte auch ich damals mit
15 sein können immer dann wenn meine
mutter mir das internet ausgestellt hat
aber er hat es wirklich wichtig ist und
hilf mir danke für diese videoproduktion
die hat mein tag persönlich bereichert
ich fühle mich jetzt deutlich besser ich
bin auch ein besserer mensch geworden
auf jeden fall also heute liegt ihr team
schlagen button checklisten für euch
vorgeschlagenes video aus und abonniert
meinen kann wenn ich das video gefallen
hat darüber freuen ich bin raus leute
ich für seine augen macht's gut